Peter ban 2002 mafia the city of lost
heaven comes out in 2010 mafia 2 comes
out yup set in Empire Bay put us out of
our misery it's 2015 mafia 3 he's been
in ads where is it set New Orleans ok
yeah it's a real place it is well it's
you know 2k and hangar 13 the developer
are referring to it as a re-imagined
version of New Orleans for now and the
game stars linking clay a black man who
was raised as an orphan and it's been
his entire life trying to find a family
he did this in the church he did this by
going to the Army in the Vietnam War and
that's really relevant to the time
period which is 1968 and that was a
pretty big you know era for America
right the murder of Martin Luther King
murder of Robert F Kennedy and you know
being set in New Orleans you have a lot
of the mix of this sort of racial
tension and political tension that's
going on with that
that's an interesting character cuz it's
you know mafia is in the title we've
been used to playing you're sort of
normal italian-american mafioso dudes
this gentleman sounds like he's not
maybe in the same sculpt as those guys
maybe not the same sculpt but you know
he goes down to New Orleans after the
war he gets them with the black mob who
has ties to the Italian mob the Italian
mob beat raised them and so then he is
left to sort of pick up the pieces and
then take down the Italian mob to
basically revenge his family more or
less and part of his crew which includes
Cassandra Burke and then Vito from the
second one mafia - yeah which is
interesting because I'm Matthew one and
two again that it wasn't like a
progression from the first one but there
was a little bit of crossover so they're
kind of doing it again having that
character in there so with these other
three characters and Burke the Irishman
yeah how can they help them your your
protagonist in this game are they just
like tagging along with you you send em
on missions right so you never actually
had a chance to play as them but what
you can do is that will based on the
mission I saw you go to a front for the
Italian mob like something you know a
storefront they're using and it's sort
of like in the basement is where all
their secret mob activity goes on and
essentially as Lincoln you go in there
and you can go many different ways you
can go underground you can go the back
entrance the front entrance anyway you
get down there you sort of go through
this this gunfight right it's lots of
cover shooting that's pretty much the
core of the action but then once you
take over the place so you can assign
any of you lieutenants
then run that area okay so essentially
what you're doing is taking over parts
of New Orleans from the mob and then
giving them to your crew is your sort of
building up your presence in the city
interesting kind of a bit like
Assassin's Creed Brotherhood or
something
I wonder an ATAR stages in the game then
will you have difficulty stretching your
sort of your resources around that world
what about that open world one of the
things about Matthew - it was criticized
I remember in Kevin's review back in
2010 was that it wasn't a game that
really adopted the open world aspect it
was really just they could have a little
bit of a playpen and then the missions
kind of happened in there did you got
any idea of how higher mafia 3 felt in
our respect we really only saw two areas
we saw the Bayou the swamp and then we
saw the sort of the French Quarter
district right and you know speaking to
the executive producer on the game
Andrew Wilson it it sounds like there's
going to be a lot of different areas to
explore but I didn't really get a great
sense of how they're connected and how
that's going to play out
but you know it New Orleans itself looks
very interesting it has a lot of things
that you would expect from the time you
know lots of jazz clubs and things like
that and there's a lot of things that
are you know touch on sensitive subject
like race issues cops and white cops are
costing black men on the street you see
lots of like key signs like you know a
wage piece instead of like wage wars and
there's a lot of like anti-war sentiment
going on do you think they're actually
like diving into that because it's a
sort of a topic that you're gonna stay
away from or sort of do it do do due
diligence yeah you can't just bring it
up and use it as a set dressing and this
was a question I asked them they assured
me that the writer in the game has a
background of handling very sensitive
issues and you know and I told him are
you ready to be scrutinized for whether
you handle this incorrectly or not and
he said we had we are doing our best to
make sure we're doing this right and you
know time will obviously tell but I
can't imagine given everything that's
happened over the past few years and
games are gonna do this without you know
double-checking everything a making sure
that they're actually handling the topic
with respect for sure
I wanted a most fantastic parts of this
series is that they did a really good
job of painting these tens these errors
everything in the radio station isn't to
like the cars you would drive and I love
having previous math video games car
driving there's so much difference to
modern games like Grand Theft Auto
because the cars were made a crappy
driving cars and car chase is gonna be a
big part of mafia 3 as well yeah car
chases are back but the thing that's
different that they highlighted during
the
is that everything is based on physics
now right and one of the things you can
do is target individual tires on cars
and it leads to a lot of explosions
pretty much every single car that I saw
that you ran door blew a tire out of it
when I flip over and explode that was a
little over the top but yeah driving is
a big part of it and their new engine
seems to be bringing something new to
that aspect of the game finally the
cover shooting aspect of this mafia one
was a game that was kind of a bunch of
different genres to get a driving game
shooter game kind of adventure game
might be a to die definitely refined us
I guess the the cover shooter game in
2010 was a bit more of a staple you
could sort of play how did this feel did
it feel like Matthew - did it feel the
woods did it feel like you were mowing
down lots of people I didn't get a
chance to actually play but the action
and the gunplay it was pretty much
you're always popped like just leaning
out of a corner to shoot somebody and I
have to wonder if that's actually what
it's going to be like all the time or if
that is sort of the way that's best to
play the game because to me it seemed to
be a sort of a OneNote pony when it came
to the action everything they were doing
was based on cover you know we'll have
to see we only saw a couple minutes of
the game and when you're going to these
events especially first time they're
often showing you something that is
perhaps the most bombastic aspect I'm
sure you know so maybe it's a game that
has its downtime moments which the only
games in the series did and what were
your sort of final impressions of it
what did you feel about this game coming
away you excited event the sort of the
narrative and the time and error and the
character they're using or or does it
feel like another third-person action
game
I'd say the themes and the setting and
the era are all very intriguing I think
you know based on the music and
everything you see around the city and
the topics that are being addressed I'm
very interested in how they're gonna
handle that story and what they're
actually going to say about Lincoln
because you know he's searching for a
family but when I asked is he actually
going to find that family they were
they're like well we don't really want
to talk about how the game ends and that
makes a lot of sense but it really makes
me want to know is this a care to who
will be able to redeem himself and find
the thing he's always been searching for
or will this be the thing that he
searches for it for the rest of his life
all right well I guess we're gonna have
to wait until 2016 to see more about
that bad boy but for more on all the
games here at Gamescom in Cologne
beautiful Cologne and stay tuned to
games.com
you